I love people so much that it it's hard
for me to be
alone that music it keeps me glued to
life Wow writer co-writer director star
co-producer this was a passion project
for you I mean right from the time you
were eight years old and got a baton for
your uh for Christmas can you just say
how you got into directing this I really
found something that I felt finally
after 20 some years in this business
that I was at my Center which was sort
of writing and directing movies and I
knew I had a huge furnace uh with this
obsession with fake conducting uh uh for
many years and um and then I just
started to and then I asked Josh singer
to come aboard and let's just see if
there's a movie that I think that maybe
that I could have a point of view about
and in researching these Incredible
characters who who Carrie so wonderfully
played as Felicia
monre
write a movie that I found utterly
compelling to explore about this
relationship of these two people that
was Haunting and inspiring and funny and
and and tragic and human and uh that was
when I knew that oh this is a movie I
could make the three Bernstein uh kids
uh who were behind this warts and all I
like to say they they didn't leave
anything off limits in this that's
absolutely correct and there is no movie
without them they were they were an
integral part of the whole writing
process they weren't around at all for
the shooting keep that very closed but
then in the post process as well I would
I would send them they would come over
to my house and I would show them cuts
of the film or scenes and they were they
were wonderful they were and and we
couldn't be at the Venice Film Festival
but people had sent us videos because
they C they went that they were
conducting the Overture at the end
during the credits with such Joy after
this movie and I I that was I felt like
we had fulfilled our task that was
really that was better than being there
Felicia uh I didn't really know much
about her but she obviously was a public
figure and an actress um what did you
learn what was the challenging uh thing
about bringing her to life well the
first time Bradley and I met was in 2018
to talk about this and in that uh coffee
he said he wanted to make a film about
marriage that was sort of how he wanted
to tell the story The Music would be a
part of this love story this kind of
possible love story it was the idea of
what it would be like to be two artists
living together and making a life
together one of whom was sort of once in
a generation touched by God talent and
the other whom was a very good actress
and what that must have felt like and
and the decision that she ultimately
made to to make Lenny her art you know
for him to become the center of her life
what I thought was so striking from the
offset was the way that Bradley and Josh
singer had been able to write this role
for a woman um so so unbelievably
truthfully um and with so much
complexity and richness but that was
just it was just shockingly brilliant
writing um and then all the other
incredible benefits of getting to work
with an actor like this there's one
scene that I still can't get out of my
head the Macy's parade and you have
snoopy the big float going behind you
where you would think the audience's eye
would go what the hell is that and it's
all on YouTube as this scene builds and
builds it was the third take it's one
single take and it was the third take of
the of that setup and then that was it
we we went home after that it was an
early day um and and it was really
because of of of Carrie being able to R
drive that scene under these very
specific circumstances and that's your
dream as a filmmaker to be able to dream
cinematically as big as you can for a
story and then have actors be able to
fulfill that that's you know that's what
you pray for I've been trying to explain
what it's like to be directed by your
co-star and um you know that Bradley did
the most extraordinary thing but I'm
still trying to get my head around it
was sort of like a Jedi Mind thing but
that that he would be able to as Lenny
elicit the response he wanted in Me by
adjusting his performance and you know
very rarely was he giving me verbal
notes they were always in character but
that so often in his performance he
would alter how ultimately I would
respond and so in that third take it was
the way Lenny walked into the room it
was the way he kept sunglasses on is the
way he had a carton of milk I mean it
was all just there you know and it was
like oh he wants a fight you know um so
it was it was it was he was directing me
through his work which is which was
incredible the work here was over the
course of several years actually in
creating um Leonard Bernstein's uh
makeup prosthetic design and everything
can you talk a little bit about this so
the uh you know Leonard Bernstein was a
big inspiration for me when I just just
started this job like 36 years ago
and uh you know I wanted to do a film
about him someday you know that's that
moment I thought yeah because it's he's
so iconic almost his face kind of oozed
with his passion and commitment and I
can I could see that what's behind it
and so you know like a uh while when I
started to work on this project and I
was thinking what drives me working so
hard every day you know last 36 years
and I realized it's almost like a get
ready for this show and Bradley brought
that you know biggest gift to me it
really reminded me the love to the
people and crew in the film making is uh
such an amazing experience it was and we
spent years years uh working on this and
I would go to his house and spend all
day long and we would just constantly
ref find it and talk about it and send
photos and talk on the phone about it
and then we would test it we we had a so
much footage of testing of Lenny to make
sure I didn't look like a SNL sketch
conducting we were Gustavo dudl was kind
enough and the LA Phil to open up Disney
Hall and we did test there and um we
just kept our goal was the same to make
a human being I actually had to call my
friends at Netflix and say is that
really Bernstein or is that Bradley
again because because I could not tell
and and it's not a mask that you put on
you can see your eyes it's so embodies
him completely but it's you it's like
it's just amazing I love the end of the
movie too because the character of of
Lenny is throughout the whole film and
it's his music and and the hope is that
you when we see this iconic figure at
the end Leonard Bernstein conducting and
then you see its music by him that you
feel that oh actually I know this person
now after this film that that was the
goal That You Don't See sort of this
Leonard burns like actually know what's
going on inside of him as he's
conducting it's amazing Michelle how did
you work with Bradley to create this
because there's a lot of uh tricks here
that uh are not easy I don't think you
know sometimes you can you work on a
project and you're like I did that or he
said this or whatever but it's I feel
like every cut was together we we
decided things together and I mean we
did it it's meant to be very seamless I
mean I always think of like this is not
a musical but this m movie is musical
you know down to the performances the
camera work and I mean the way Bradley
created a lot of these transitions or
design them and shot it that way that
you know really the job of editorial was
to try to create you know a musical flow
throughout the entire film and it's
really across scenes and across sequence
es that you know we try to land in in in
important moments in their relationship
the only reason why we change uh time
periods is because again that anchor of
the movie is about this marriage and in
order to tell the story we had to cross
decades five decades and early on when I
spoke to everybody it was about we're
not we're going to do that in a way
there's not it's not going to say 1966
or 1971 we have to do it with how the
movie feels and also never wanting the
audience to be outside of the film
always immersed that's why the 133
aspect ratio and it's always depth and
that comes down to creating a world that
Kevin Thompson and his team created Uh
Kevin you know the Dakota does not allow
cameras in there at all ever and so how
did you recreate this go about doing
that set in particular it doesn't allow
movie shooting but it allowed me to take
pictures with my
iPhone and and I was able to get my team
members in uh to to measure basic uh
overall scale dimensions and details of
the woodwork and things like that so we
but I think it was important for Bradley
and I just to walk through the apartment
and talk about where we are in the movie
with these two characters and their
relationship and what the Dakota meant
to them and their family at that time
and we walked through the apartment and
we talked about
how subtle adjustments should be made to
the plan um to work better for how
Bradley wanted to shoot it so we
discussed that and then and then it was
it's a dream of mine um to be able to
build a set like that and have it be
more than just a tangible reproduction
of an apartment but something that
carried the emotional core of what was
going to happen there again all this the
opportunity of having so much time so
many years of prep so I would walk in I
mean I went to that the owner of the
Dakota was so nice I went there maybe
four times before we went I was able to
go on Thanksgiving Day and see how they
sort of entertained there which gave me
so many ideas with with the house it was
I mean I was there half a dozen times
and I fell in love with it and wrote
much of the movie you know in the black
and white era and the color of this home
same thing with elely Cathedral we had
to go to elely Cathedral where Lenny did
uh you know conduct Mer's second
Symphony the resurrection with the
London Symphony Orchestra in the 70s
Mark talk about uh the costume Des
design here and what your biggest
challenge was too I understand they
actually wore went into the closet and
wore some of the real stuff that uh uh
yeah one of uh car's uh costumes was one
of Felicia's real dresses uh that she
wears at the country house and Jamie was
very generous and loaned it to us and it
went right on Carrie and I think it adds
to the scene with its energy of of
Felicia there somehow and it was also
something very typically that she would
wear so um you know we Bradley and I
poured over tons of images and and uh
looked at what maybe would work for the
Beats of the lifetime different eras
that you had to go through in one movie
here and make it believable that was
that was the most exciting part of it
really is go from 1943 to
1989 and and try to tell a story with a
a shoulder pad or a hemline or a shape
of a trouser texture for the black and
white using colors judiciously
throughout the color sequence just
everything with the goal of telling the
story thanks for sticking thank you so
much for coming out here to the academy
tonight thanks guys thank
[Applause]
you